what is a beta and i've also heard
a gamma and omega you're talking you're
talking about you're talking about
socio-sexual hierarchy yes exactly what
is it socio-sexual hierarchies there's
alpha beta
gamma omega if you want you want me to
give you an education here in a quick uh
i'll be as fast as i can here okay so
sigma mail so sociosexual hierarchies
there's alpha beta delta gamma and omega
if you really okay and then some people
say oh there's a sigma too um
these were designations actually that
were uh brought up and i think were
popularized by a blogger and uh uh
actually i think he's still on youtube
now he's called uh voxday and he's got
some real if you ever want to get a
really good education in like
sociosexual pull up the um social sexual
hierarchy so we can get a picture of
this thank you tyler and so he he
brought the idea that alpha is one
designation beta images hit images yeah
beta is sort of his which imagery hit
that one right there
with the taurus bull yeah boom
you got alpha at the top aka sigma
then you have a beta because beta i feel
like people think that beta beta is the
side kick he's the robin
baden is the uh alpha is the batman beta
is the robin is the yeah beta's kind of
like the sidekick the guy who hangs out
with the alpha because he wants to get
the leftovers from down gotcha okay the
delta is kind of like the the vast
majority of guys which is like they're
they go along to get along they just
survive they get a good job they do what
they're what they believe is expected of
them they're not looking for and they're
not like ambitious they're not very like
they're they're worker bees right
they're worth the worker the average
thanks right then there's the gammas
gammas tend to be very uh analytical and
it's like i can't understand why you
wouldn't want to get with me because i'm
the perfect guy and let me tell you let
me give you this yeah let me give you
this uh what was the gamma you meant
like is there a case example you can
give us real quick what is that all the
time people who text me like
how much money do you have to pay you to
meet up with you unbelievable or like
yes yeah or or they'll give you this
detailed list of all of their great uh
provider qualities
i'm the one that logically deductively
uh i'm the guy that you should be with i
can't understand why you're banging the
are you saying that these are the nice
guys why nice guys finish last they're
the ones that say i'm a nice guy and she
won't get with me but it's entitlement
nice guy finishes last night okay well
you know it's funny and vox day is a
example here when he's talking about
gammas he says when women are they don't
understand like that if they don't
understand the sociosexual hierarchies
they'll meet a gamma and they'll have
this uh this irresistible urge to punch
the guy in the face
even if we understand that we still have
that
it's intuitive okay but he's not even
the lowest who's the lowest the omega is
kind of like what's the guy on the off
or what was the um office space you see
office space have you seen my stapler
yeah the guy that's at the very bottom
yeah that's omega yeah we're gonna need
you to move again
that's the omega that's the the guy
who's never he doesn't get it and is
never going to get it and is uh to the
point where it's like almost like those
are the people you gotta [ __ ] look
out for omega because he's the guy that
blew up the building these are the
school shooters yes these are
these are the guys that get no action
and they you stole my stapler and then
this is what happens right so they're
very careful for these omegas the
nurturer in me is like
here's the question ladies would you
give it up to a guy like that if he was
a billionaire no not even no of course
okay
if he needed a stapler would you give
him a statement yes okay
well thank you for that breakdown so
that's important and then people are
going to say well what's a sigma okay
sigma male is like sort of the lone wolf
like he wants to be outside of the whole
hierarchy yeah um i'm of mixed uh
mixed uh reactions when it comes to that
because i think it's just another it's
just another archetype of ladies
gentlemen if you could oh this picture
right here can you go back this is great
that guy is
if you could i'd like to put a tangible
case example to each of those things if
you can go back to that image tyler and
say you know
the alpha okay leonardo dicaprio boom
all right got it uh
beta
you know if you could um he's going to
pull it up with the best sociosexual
hierarchy the best example of that image
okay top gun like okay tom cruise
of that movie hell yeah his sidekick the
guy maverick is the beta no that was
goof goose
he was maverick yeah he's the baby
he's the sidekick he's still getting the
robin to the batman but he's not
definitely not there so does every alpha
need a beta sidekick like a homie not
necessarily all right i don't know i
don't know dog
just because just because you label
something with specific terminology
doesn't necessarily mean that it
reflects reality which is why like a
youtuber a youtuber created this yes
but i also think every single alpha that
i've met in my life other than you guys
um anybody sorry not every single outfit
let me let me say something a little bit
more precise yes every single man that
i've met who's called himself an alpha
and made a point to say it out loud
um has been
the most triggered by an independent
woman or by any kind of uh retaliation
to that opinion
like they cannot hold their own without
getting that's a gamma trying to get up
into alpha class is what that is ooh
for example they might kick women off of
their show but i do because they can't
contend with that well wait wait wait
wait wait
juan where do you think that that's them
being emotional or trying to establish
rules two things i think
trying to establish rules that that
would insinuate that you're having a
conversation with somebody who needs to
be trained
which i disagree with training secondly
i also think that on that show there's
more of not that show specifically any
show that we're talking about uh
ambiguously
there's an emphasis on
there's a huge emphasis on getting views
and what gets views is is making a drama
so if for example somebody says that she
believes that her husband or her man
should cook as well and you get so
triggered by that you have to kick them
off of your show
to me that is very telling about the
kind of man that you are
so you're saying that person is not an
alpha and in reality it might be a gamma
protein i don't put labels on people
like that that's the only thing by the
way i'm looking for labels here to be
honest with you i want labels so i can
understand this i know and a lot of
people do they want the step-by-step
they want give me something identified
here's what i and i appreciate your
point i do and nobody likes to be
labeled and we don't like which is why
generalizations but i do like to see who
fits into these categories
which is why i always say i don't like i
mean i
understand i understand this but when
you read my work and i say alpha or beta
i distill it down to those two i don't i
don't know
i understand it and i'm not saying i
disagree with it i'm just saying again
it's like how do you like
there's the alpha as a demographic and
then there's the alpha as like a mindset
so got it where does that fit into
something like this that's why i have a
like people say i'm a sigma well no
you're not a sigma you just want to be
out you think you're like outsider you
think you're like you know uh you know
johnny depp or something you think
you're outside of the the the system and
you're really not you are in the system
and the very fact that you would call
yourself a sigma or call yourself an
alpha or call yourself or whatever
that to me says
that you're
a king a rich man doesn't have to tell
you he's rich you get you by his
demeanor by his his uh you know how he
speaks what he's wearing everything else
you can get that a guy doesn't have to
come in there go i'm really rich like
when you're talking about uh have you
ever lied about your uh your income or
whatever i've i've never been in the
position where i've had to do anything
like that but like if i walk into a room
or you walk into a room or like if
you're if you're dressed down people
don't know like say a guy like george
gammon is like a multi-millionaire
because he just dresses in like you know
a
jacket and a t-shirt and everything so
you don't really get that from him but
he doesn't go in there and say hey guys
i'm michael miller in books he doesn't
do that because he it's his
exactly you don't alpha confident guy
doesn't say i'm confident he doesn't
have to tell you like you get it all
right well thank you for breaking this
down i think we all have a better
understanding
[Music]
you